in the past six weeks the global weekly
number of reported cases of covet 19 has
almost doubled
this are also increasing
but for the moment
and not as rapidly as cases
however more cases means we can expect
to see more hospitalizations and this in
the coming weeks
there are many sub lineages of the
omicron variant most notably ba5
which is the most transmissible variant
detected yet
we have said consistently that this
virus will continue to evolve
and we must be ready for whatever it
throws at us
that could be a new version of the
variants we already know
or something completely new
we know that for any future variant to
become widespread
it must be more transmissible than
previous variants
but we can't know how deadly it will be
so all countries must be ready
countries that have dismantled some
parts of their pandemic response systems
are taking a huge risk
all countries have gaps
now is the time
when hospitals are not full
for all countries to address those gaps
in surveillance immunity
workforce supplies and resilience
we will see continued waves of infection
but we need not see continued waves of
hospitalization
and death death
we have the tools to save lives
vaccines tests therapeutics and public
health tools